Hello 大家好，我是曼儿。今天又来给大家讲商业故事了。Ready？ Go！
那今天讲的什么故事呢？就是最近点报舆论的新闻事件，上海迪士尼的优素通。
那么首先啊，如果大家还没有看到或者说听到过这个新闻事件，我来给大家简单讲讲这是个啥。
那就是在2026年，就是今年这一年的五一黄金周。
在上海迪士尼乐园里面，有一位父亲带着女儿排了整整三个小时的队，就为了玩一个热门的项目。
那他眼看到了队伍的前端，生力在望，马上要坐上去的时候，突然啊，旁边的这个付费专用通道俗称优素通不断的用出游客，
不断插入他们的前面，大摇大摆的在他眼前直接上车。
那优素通是迪士尼乐园推出的付费快速排队业务。
他比起普通的队伍能够更快速地玩上项目，可以单个项目买差不多是在120块钱到180块钱左右。
那当然你也可以给我买套餐了，就好几个项目叠加在一起。
那么这位父亲就眼看着不断有人就插入他的队伍，他终于也崩溃了。
在视频里面，他对着工作人员怒吼，我们排了三个小时，他们凭什么直接进来？
你迪士尼乐园就是谁交钱多就放谁进去是吗？
那当然啊，我的这个描述只是一个讲话版。
所以也建议大家看看原视频，虽然只是一个小小的片段，但是也避免端章取义嘛。
那anyway，这段视频就被传到网上了，24小时之内播放两颗千万评论去瞬间诈成两派。
那么一派呢，火力全开，抗议迪士尼乐园。
很多人说，排了三小时被插队，那换谁都会崩溃嘛。
说这个优素通就是花钱买特权赤裸裸的借机歧视。
还有人说，即便花钱可以买时间，难道迪士尼乐园就能为了赚更多的钱，
损害那些只买了门票的普通游客的权益吗？
那这是一派。
那么另外一派呢，冷嘲热讽说，哎，这个迪士尼又不是慈善组织嘛，
作为一个企业要赚钱，为什么不能推出这种产品呢？
人家规则写的清清楚楚，优素通本来就存在，那你买不起就别算。
还有人说，穷就牢牢实实排队，又想省钱又想优先，你想什么没事呢？
那当然，这些争论都有道理，
但如果我们只停留在谁对谁错，那可能会错过更重要的问题。
因为从商业视角来看，迪士尼乐园早就把排队管理和时间商业化这件事情玩得炉火纯青了，
我愿意称其为时间管理大使。
那在付费的优素通出现之前，1990年代就出现了免费的素通票叫做Fast Pass。
很多人会说，你看最早迪士尼还是免费的嘛，对不对，还是挺有道德，挺有良心的。
才不是呢，免费的素通票就是为了让你不排队，把你解放出来，
可以在园区里面花更多的时间逛，有更多的时间吃饭买东西，给它创造更多的收入。
那当然，我并不是诟病或者说审判迪士尼乐园做商业化嘛，
那我们就从商业化的视角来看，当这个曾经的免费素通票变为了付费的优素通，
看似增加了收入，但是会不会给普通游客带来更多糟糕的体验。
从而反倒降低未来的长期收入呢，因为虽然是普通游客也不代表着他一辈子只会来一次嘛。
而另外一个问题是，如果付费的优素通也不断的泛滥，花了钱买了时间的人越来越多，
那么也要开始排队，经历长时间的等待。
那买和不买的区别是啥呢？就是一个多花钱一个少花钱吗？
虽然很多人说迪士尼乐园的优素通是有限量的售卖的，
但是这是一个黑箱子，没有人知道限量多少，财报也是不披露的。
而且迪士尼乐园曾经的免费版的这个素通票也出现过类似的问题，一开始是限量发的，
后来大家喜欢它就开始多发，最后就泛滥了。
那么在这种情况下，我们也还是站在纯商业的视角来看，
如果未来那些花了额外的钱的游客，体验依旧糟糕，那迪士尼乐园又该怎么办呢？
而从道德的视角来看，虽然我们老说这个谈商业就别谈道德，
但是最近我也在反思，即便我们不谈道德，但是是不是也需要一个底线呢？
或者说商业它当然作为企业，它不谈道德，
但是消费者是个人，它不可能完全避弃道德的考量的。
尤其是迪士尼乐园一直标榜自己是全世界最快乐的地方，
但是现在看起来就要打个问号了，这个地方到底是制造了魔法的快乐，
还是人为整密的制造了排队的痛苦呢？
如果我再更负黑一点，
如果确实是先制造排队的痛苦，
再售卖这种付费的优速通作为解药，
这个有没有道德问题呢？
最后从社会阶级的视角来看，
优速通最刺痛人的其实不是价格本身，
而是它把不平等从隐性的变成了显性的。
在很多地方没钱是看不见的，
大家买同样的门票，排同样的队伍，
至少在物理空间上是平等的，
但是优速通制造了这种阶级通道，
一条给愿意付费的人，唱通无阻，
一条只能给等待的人，你就排队吧。
其实网上已经有不少的讨论了，
不是只有迪士尼乐园才能让这种穷展露出来，
飞机的头顿舱，医院的VIP号，
银行的VIP专门柜台，
大家是真的不知道，
或者说看不见这种阶级差吗？
不是的。
所以更有意思的问题就是，
为什么在迪士尼乐园这种阶级的不平等。
能够更轻易的被觉察，
被放大，被点燃？
所以今天这期节目，
我们就来拆解这场迪士尼乐园排队冲锄背后的。
深层商业和阶级逻辑问题。
但是讲更深入的东西之前，
我们先来点轻松的，
说说排队这件事情吧。
迪士尼的排队到底能有多夸张呢？
五一假期的时候，
上海迪士尼的飞跃地平线项目，
排队时间一度达到三个半小时，
这意味着你早上九点纪远，
排完这个项目出来已经是中午的十二点半了。
而这个项目本身只能玩五分钟。
再比如说这个创急速光轮，
高峰期能排队三个小时，
七个小二人矿山车两个小时起义，
就连相对比较冷门的加勒比海盗，
节假日也差不多要排队四十分钟到一个小时。
美国迪士尼的情况也好不到哪儿去，
根据2025年的数据来看，
迪士尼世界平均每个项目的等待时长差不多是40分钟。
但注意这个是平均值、热门项目，
比如说像是星球大战、阿凡达，
排队两到三个小时也是常态。
我之前忘了在哪看到过一个数据，
这个不一定真，
但是它有个说法，
说在迪士尼乐园里面，
你有80%的时间是在排队，
只有20%的时间是在玩。
假设你在园区里面待10个小时，
其实就是8个小时在排队，
真正玩项目的时间不到2个小时。
但比较有意思的是什么呢？
单单排队这件事情，
好像本身并不是什么问题，
因为我们生活中，
到处都是排队，
餐厅也要排队，
银行也要排队，
医院也要排队，
问题是，
为什么迪士尼的排队，
特别让人崩溃呢？
如果表层一点说，
其实是我们对于
做不同事情排队的情绪，
是不一样的吗？
就是你餐厅排队，
我现在还没花钱呢，
我只是取了个号，
看到前面有100桌，
哎，我有点点情绪，
但是我可以走吗？
去吃别了，
下次再来就好了。
银行排队，
现在银行数字话，
其实已经做的比较好了，
很多的操作，
它其实都可以先上做，
到了线下，
即便我取号的时候，
发现前面的人很多，
我还是能够看看，
究竟是不是有其他网点，
我换一个网点，
毕竟银行的网点，
布局也是相对密集的，
医院就更别说了，
排队就排着吧，
能把我的病治好，
才是最重要的，
但是乐园不一样，
我要等的是三个小时，
这个首先量级，
就是不一样的了，
而且,
除此之外，
我是先花了门票钱的，
这个钱我已经先交给你了，
等我入园发现，
要排队三个小时的时候，
你不可能再给我推了，
我能没有情绪吗？
这就是乐园排队的一个特殊性，
它是先付费的，
你不能退，
你也没得选，
一旦你的体验崩溃了，
你以后就不会再来了，
甚至你还会再网上网，
影响更多的人不来，
所以,
如果我们换个市场，
对于迪士尼乐园来说，
排队不是一个单纯的游客抱怨的问题，
而是直接关系到它的商业模式了，
当然,
我不是说，
它的这些设施项目的可玩性，
氛围,
花车巡演，
服务,
这些都不重要，
而是排队，
或者说人流管理，
时间管理，
对于迪士尼乐园，
这一个企业来说，
其实是整个运营的最核心问题之一，
那么问题又来了，
既然排队这么重要，
迪士尼该怎么解决呢？
很多人的第一反应会说，
既然问题是排队，
你少卖点票不就好了吗？
现在卖的肯定是太多了，
确实,
一座迪士尼乐园的，
能容纳的人数最大容量，
是有上限的，
这个通常会考虑一些，
设施的承载量，
排队区域的容量，
公共区域的容量，
交通服务容量，
等等,
复杂的要素，
但是,
它理论上，
是有上限的，
确实,
如果卖票卖的太多了，
游客的体验很差，
但是,
如果卖票卖的太少了，
就做迪士尼乐园，
差不多要运营10年到20年，
才能够回本，
我们不是说引力，
而是说回本，
因为前期投入，
真的是太过膨大了，
像上海迪士尼乐园，
我之前看到过，
应该是初期投资是350亿，
对吧,
怎么可能，
就这么容易，
就少卖门票呢，
对不对，
而且,
即便迪士尼乐园，
把入园的人数，
控制下来了，
或者说，
小于它的最大容量，
但是,
如果所有入园的人，
一开始，
冲入园区的时候，
都挤在这个，
热门项目前面排队，
那你体验，
依然会崩，
所以,
迪士尼需要的，
不一定，
我只说不一定，
是少卖票，
而是让同样数量的人，
玩项目玩得更畅快，
这个,
才是它的运营模仿，
那,
这就很有意思了嘛，对不对，
排队玩项目，
这本质上不就是，
我们经济学当中的，
供需关系吗，
如果小伙伴，
了解这个，
供需关系曲线的话，
就会知道说，
诶，我这个，
那个交汇点，
就是决定了价格跟销量嘛，
那么在迪士尼乐园当中，
供给就是，
一个个设施项目的，
这个最大承载量，
比如说，
像这个创机组光轮，
它一天不间断运行下来，
能接待的最大人数，
其实就是它的供给，
而需求是啥呢，
就是排队的人数，
那这两个曲线交汇的那个点，
最后决定了，
等待时间，
和实际乘坐的人数，
所以你看，
在普通商品，
供需关系当中的这个价格，
不就等同于，
迪士尼乐园当中的，
等待时间了吗，
所以才说，
时间就是金钱嘛，
但是呢，
就是迪士尼乐园，
它会更复杂一点点，
为什么，
因为它不同项目，
能接待的这个，
最大人数是不一样的，
它不同项目的，
排队人数也是不一样的，
这就是为什么，
排队管理，
显得有位重要了，
如果大家都，
只去热门的项目，
那很可能，
所有人一天下来，
只能平均玩三个项目，
但是,
如果我能，
掠施小魔法，
能引导大家，
多去一些，
相对冷门的项目，
那就有可能，
让所有人，
一天平均下来，
能玩四个项目，
那体验感觉就不一样了，
所以,
解决排队，
对迪士尼乐园来说，
是生死攸关的商业问题，
不是说，
我要不要做好服务的，
这种道德问题，
而是能不能够，
持续引力的，
这么一个商业问题，
而确实，
迪士尼乐园，
在排队管理上面，
已经是，
老手当中的老手了，
而且它很早，
就意识到这个问题了，
有一套，
一直在演化的，
排队管理系统。
我不知道，
大家知不知道，
就是1955年，
迪士尼第一座，
加州乐园，
其实是采用，
这种入园门票，
加项目，
乘坐票，
两部分构成的，
就当时，
你入园的时候，
要花一美元的门票进入，
你买的是个啥呢，
是个入园的权利，
那进去之后，
不同的项目，
是要额外收费的，
小的项目，
可能五美分，
就能够，
做一做，玩一玩，
那大的项目，
五十美分，
才能够乘坐，
那你有没有，
这个闪回，
不知道大家有没有联想到，
现在不就是，
我们在单独，
购买了门票之后，
还可以花钱，
额外购买优速通，
那虽然内核不一样，
但是确实是有些相似性的，
最早的这种，
额外项目门票，
买的其实是一个，
乘坐权，
你买的就能做，
那现在的优速通，
买的是一个优先权，
但都是额外费用，
所以你看这个，
现在不就走回了，
1955年的那条，
老路嘛，对吧，
但是呢，
随着时间推进到了，
1959年的时候，
那迪士尼呢，
进一步发明出了，
一个券测系统，
把这种不同项目的收费，
给标准化了，
啥意思呢，
就是,
游客花钱入园之后呢，
还需要花钱购买，
一个兑换券测子，
这里面呢，
就是一个standard的，
就是标准化的，
它包含了好多张，
这个兑换券，
它会分成，
A-1,
五个级别，
而乐园里面的每个项目呢，
也会分成A-1，
五个级别，
A是最低级别的项目，
一是这种最高级的，
最热门，
最好玩的项目，
那你想玩哪一个项目呢，
只要在项目的那个，
检刨口，
撕下一张相应的这个兑换券，
给到检票远就可以了，
那如果券用完了，
你还可以在额外购买，
这种单独的，
单张卖的这种券，
那这个系统就非常聪明了，
虽然在没有等级的时候，
大家也知道哪个项目贵，
哪个项目便宜嘛，
但是有了这套系统之后呢，
首先,
诶，游客就可以更直观的知道，
那些是热门项目了，
那同时，
迪士尼还可以通过这个券册，
控制人流，
你看啊，
最重要的目的是控制人流，
比如说这个券册里面，
可能会给你四张A等级的券，
三张B等级的券，
一张E等级的，
就是这个最好玩的项目的券，
那这个时候，
大家有了这么一个资源包，
就会自己开始考虑，
如何合理有效的分配资源了，
那但是我原区里没有，
三个E等级的设施，
那你这个券里面，
只要包含E上，
怎么办？
虽然,
你还可以额外再买单独的，
这个E等级的券，
但是这个券册，
它会让很多游客，
产生一种心理，
我先把这个券册，
用完再说，
用完了，
我再额外买，
所以确实，
实际上，
很多游客在用完了之后，
只完了一个E等级的项目，
那这个就能够，
很好的分流了嘛，
对不对，
就减少这种，
热门项目的排队时间，
因为我们刚刚讲的，
假设这个圆区里面有三个E等级的，
但你这个券册里面，
只有一张E等级的，
那这个时候，
游客就会开始自动地分流了，
那么这个A到E的。
券册系统，
其实是非常有名的，
甚至到后来，
这个E ticket,。
就是E票券，
这个词，
已经演变成了，
最贵,
最稀有，
最热门的，
这种代名词，
比如说像是
An E ticket event,。
就是重磅赛事的意思，
An E ticket acquisition,。
就是重量级的收购，
这个意思，
等等等等，
那么随着时间的推移，
就是A到E的这个券册系统，
也开始失灵了，
因为首先，
这个A到E的这个项目排序，
是迪士尼自己认为的排序，
但是游客实际体验之后，
又会发现有些E项目，
他排了老半天，
还不如CD项目呢，
会有这种错配感，
所以导致体验不是特别好，
起次,
对于已经来过一次，
体验过所有项目的游客来说，
他第二次再来的时候，
他就不会去直接买这个券册了，
他反倒是可以单独购买这个票券嘛，
他就直接去玩这个最热门的项目了，
所以实际上呢，
迪士尼也不能通过这种券册，
来控制老玩家的这个行为，
于是到了1982年的时候，
券册系统正式推出了历史舞台，
那么迪士尼呢，
就开始采用One Price Admission,。
就是E票通，
我只收你一个入源的门票，
就不再收取额外的项目费用了，
就跟现在的模式很类似了，
但是一票通呢，
他不是也不能解决排队的问题吗？
就是大家买了票，
还是会一股脑的一窝风的，
去挤入那个热门的项目当中排队，
你体验还是会差呀，
那怎么办？
于是迪士尼开始尝试新招了，
一开始呢，
他是在排队本身这件事情上面，
问话一样，
我队伍太长怎么办？
我给你搞出一个叫做switchback queue，
就是折返对立，
他通过压缩空间，
让队伍更有秩序，
那么当时呢，
这个迪士尼本人，
还认为这种设计有非常强的，
这种心理学优势，
因为有客在来回折返的时候，
他会不断的与其他游客面对面，
他说,
这个会增加陌生人跟陌生人之间的互动，
那么当然呢，
就是这个折返队伍这件事情，
并不是迪士尼发明的，
而且早在他们自己第一个园区，
就是那个加州迪士尼乐园，
1955年开的时候，
就已经有了，
只不过呢，
就是在改成这种one price admission，
一票通知后，
迪士尼进一步优化了这个系统，
迪士尼他很聪明哦，
在排队这件事情上面，
有三条规则，
第一条规则，
就是尽可能把时间，
控制在15分钟之内，
那当然，
这个很难实现吧，
不太可能，
所以第二条规则呢，
就是在排队的时候，
给游客去看这些娱乐内容，
所以排队等待的时候，
就会有很多的这种互动元素，
会让你看短片，
甚至会有些IP的这个角色，
来跟你握手，
跟你虚寒问暖，
然后呢，
这个队伍的周围的这些装饰，
也让你有非常强的这种沉浸的感觉，
那这个是第二条规则，
那么第三条规则呢，
就更简单粗暴一点点哦，
就是尽量把队伍隐藏起来，
让游客无法一眼看出，
队伍到底有多长，
这个真的是太有意思了对吧，
所以去过迪士尼的这个小伙伴，
相信非常有提感，
很多项目他不是在入口排队的，
而是进入了那个入口之后，
在室内，内部空间排队，
你没进去之前，
你根本不知道这个队伍有多长，
而且进去之后，
你有时候排着排着走着走着，
以为走到头了，
结果发现，
哎，怎么是要下个楼梯，
哎，怎么进到另外一个区域当中了，
哎，怎么这个七怪八怪之后，
还有一个拐，
就是山有小口从口入，
出击下财通人，
复兴数十步，
才发现更多人，
对吧，就是这种感觉。
但不管如何吧，
这个迪士尼排队的第二条规则，
跟第三条规则，
加上折返队列，
都是为了从心理层面，
对游客产生一个影响。
虽然你等待的时长，
没有变化，
但是心里面感觉呢，
好像耗了一点点，
治愈了一点点，
又短了一点点，
只不过，
这个东西，
它治标不治本嘛，
你第一次去的游客，
可能还能忽得住，
觉得说，
哎呀，体验真的非常好，
但是到了第二次以后，
管你什么忽动，
排队就是排队，
隐藏式的排队，
还会让人更愤怒，
对不对，
你怎么还在给我搞这一套，
所以折返队伍的系统，
也开始撑不住了，
这个时候，
就有一个关键人物登场了，
叫做 Bruce Laval,。
他毕业于佛罗里达大学的。
NBA专业,
主修的就是运营管理，
当时,
券测系统出现了一系列的。
搓配问题，
老玩家操控不了的问题，
也是 Laval发现的，
Laval也很快速的报告了。
他的发现，
只是,
系统用了十几年了，
迪士尼很难抛弃，
所以才一直拖到
1982年的时候，
才取消嘛，
改成了这种一票通的形式，
但是不管如何，
Laval是有这个能力，
能够来去识别到
排队管理当中的一些问题，
所以在取消了这个。
券测系统之后，
改成一票通了之后，
就是迪士尼就让Laval。
肩负重任，
开始研究新的方案，
来进行这个排队管理了，
在研究的过程当中，
Laval的一个核心动差是什么呢？
就是人们讨厌的不是等待，
而是无意义的等待，
如果你必须站在
免干等，
那你每一分钟都是煎熬的，
但如果告诉你说，
两个小时之后回来，
你就能坐上，
那这两个小时呢，
你可以去吃饭，
去购物，看巡演，
随便逛一逛，
那这个时候，
等待它就不再是痛苦的，
反倒变成了一个你的自由事件，
而基于此，
Laval第一个新的主意，
就是针对于火热的项目，
完全实行这种预约制，
就完全去取消排队的制度，
它的核心思路很简单，
就是任何一个游客都可以。
提前获得一个预约的时间，
就跟你餐厅预约是一样的，
给你留好了这个位置，
你到了时间，
你就直接进入到项目当中，
你也不需要排队了嘛，对吧，
但是呢，
它小规模的测试了一阵子，
很快呢，就发现了一些问题，
第一个问题就是，
其实很多游客可能会错过这个时间，
因为远区很大嘛，
你一旦没有留够足够充足的时间，
你就会赶不上，
你很可能是从这个远区的东边，
一路小跑到西边，对不对，
那这个时候，
这个项目的座位就会被空出来了，
那这就浪费了嘛，
还记得我们前面最早说的。
这个经济学的供需关系原理嘛，对不对，
如果你这个座位空出来了，
又没有人做，
这不就是白白浪费嘛，
那这些设施跟项目就没有发挥出，
他们最大的这个承载量啊，
那除此之外呢，
第二个问题就是，
如果有突发情况怎么办，
比如说像是项目，
突然这个故障停机了，
虽然我可能可以在较短的时间内，
检修完毕，重新启动，
但是原本预约了这个时段的游客，
就无法再乘坐了呀，
你后面的预约也都约满了，排满了，
那怎么办，
这种情况下，
反倒更会放大游客的这种不满情绪，
所以这个方案呢，
也被跑弃了，
直到1997年，
就是据说Level突然获得了一个新的灵感，
这个是在它跑去滑雪的时候获得的灵感，
它那一年呢，去滑雪的时候呢，
就发现了滑雪厂里面的懒车排队很有意思，
就一台懒车，
它有四个座位嘛，
那排队等懒车的这个队伍呢，
就被分成了两条，
一条呢，是普通队伍，
一条叫做Single Rider,。
就是单人补位的队伍，
如果啊，这个普通队伍中的一组游客，
比方说三个人对吧，
它没有办法填满一台懒车，
哎，那这个时候单人补位队伍的游客，
就可以补上去，
那你这个时候，
不就可以更进一步的优化，
这些座位的利用率了嘛，
节省事件，
所以它突然意识到了，
这个呢，就是迪士尼要走的方向，
那迪士尼乐园的项目也需要两条队伍，
一条就是预约队伍，
它可以提前预约事件，
然后呢，去园区玩别的，
到了时间再回来，
那么另外一条就是普通队伍了，
那这条队伍呢，
就是依旧需要站着排队的，
但这里啊，
我们需要解释一下，
为什么这种形式，
它能够成立呢，
就是Level提出来这个预约，
它可不是像我们定餐厅一样，
哎，我打个电话，
晚上七点吃饭，
餐厅就会帮你空出来，
Level的这个预约制度，
依旧是先到先得的概念，
啥意思？
比如说，你这个一大早，
在迪士尼钢开员的时候，
你就冲去了这个飞越地平线的项目，
你发现说，哎，
这个普通队伍前面，
有这个几十个人在排队，
那你可能会觉得说，
排一下也无所谓嘛，
就几十个人，
那你就直接排普通队伍，
你等着去玩就好了，
但是如果你慢了一步，
过去的时候发现，
这个队伍已经开始变长了，
那这个时候，
你就有两个选择了，
你可以依旧选择在普通队伍去排队等待，
那么另外一个选择，
就是在项目的前面，
用一个机器去领一个预约券，
这个系统会告诉你说，
哎，你两个小时之后再回来，
你就可以直接玩了，
但是注意哦，
我们刚刚讲了嘛，对吧，
这个不是你不需要等待了，
你依旧是在整个系统里面，
和普通队伍一起排队的，
只是你不需要站着等待，
而是在远去里面，
逛着等待，
从站着排，
变成拿号，
出去走着排，
所以呢，
这种形式也被称为virtual queue，
就是虚拟排队，
它不需要你physical里物理的站在那里，
那这套系统的好处是什么呢，
是它不仅仅让游客减少了。
这个站着等待的时间，
它还能让你玩更多的项目，
本来你是要在项目A门口排队的，
比方说你要排一个小时好了，
但是有这套系统，
你就可以领一个预约券，
虽然等的时间要更长，
让你两个小时之后再回来，
因为两个小时大于一个小时嘛，对吧，
但是这两个小时，
站在那排队，
两个小时你可以完全利用起来，
去玩其他的一个项目，对不对，
所以这一套排队系统，
就是当时Leval研发出来的一个系统，
也是现在很多人都知道的，
叫做fastpass系统，
叫做速通票系统，
而Leval为了说服我们这个。
迪士尼乐园的高层管理层，
它就立刻开始做这个AB test，
一组就是这个正常的对照组，
一组就采用速通票的这种模式，
是一个测试组，
测试的结果当然极其成功了，
速通票组的这个游客多完了25%的项目，
但是减少了50%的排队时间，
当然游客的满意度，
就搜搜搜地提升上去了，对不对，
但是如果我们从迪士尼的视角来去看，
我搞这么一套系统，
虽然游客满意度提升了，
那我迪士尼乐园有什么好处呢，
搞这套东西它不也需要成本嘛，对不对，
哎，别着急，
这个测试当中还有个更有意思的数据，
回答了这个问题，
当你站在队伍里面排队的时候，
你能做什么，
你什么都做不了，
你不能去商店，
不能去餐厅，
不能去看表演，
你的时间跟注意力都被锁死在这条队伍当中了，
但是你有了速通票，
你突然有了这个自由时间，
这两个小时你可以干嘛，
逛街，吃饭，买东西啊，对吧，
所以在测试结果当中，
相比于对照组，
速通票的这个测试组。
明显花了更多的钱在远去消费，
所以啊，
这是为什么当时迪士尼决定要把速通票。
免费开放给所有人，
因为速通票虽然免费，
但是会产生其他额外的一些收入。
那当然啊，
这个我觉得应该不仅仅只是纯商业考虑啊，
我看到当时有很多说法是说，
其实迪士尼乐园内部，
很多人也认为说，
应该要回归初心，
他们不想要在乐园里面出现。
这种不同阶级的游客，
那我理解，
他们就是不想通过这种支付能力，
把阶级的遮袖布给撕开，
这跟他们从一开始这种入园票，
加项目票的形式，
改成一票通是一样的，
那个时候入园票加项目票的时候，
对把游戏项目收费贵，
那就有人买不起，
他就玩不了，
所以这个确实会产生一定的这种阶级感，
但是改成一票通之后，
他就没有这种阶级感了，
所以为什么速通票也是一开始免费发放的，
除了我们说商业利益以外，
他也有这种感觉，
希望所有人进入这个圆区，
能够被以示同仁的对待。
于是在1999年，
迪士尼乐园就正式推出了这个速通票系统，
所有游客一是同仁先到先得。
那么形式上就是我刚刚描述的，
游客来到项目入口的时候，
就可以看到两条队伍，
普通队伍上会显示等待时长，
如果你能接受，
那你就直接去排队，
如果你觉得时间太长了，
你就可以去项目旁边的一个兑换机器上面，
拎这个速通票，
那游客只需要把自己的门票插入进去，
机器就会打印出一个这个项目的速通票，
上面会给你一个小时的时间区间，
比如说下午两点到三点，
你只要在这个时段里的任意时间回来，
就可以排上速通队伍。
那听到这儿，
我不知道大家脑子里面我冒出来更多的问题，
反正我是有的。
比如说，我举手，
比如说我在普通队伍入口看到的时间，
是怎么计算的？
因为不是还有速通票的队伍会插入进来吗？
大家会不会confused？
再比如说，
我怎么去控制速通票的数量呢？
如果你数量太多了，
最后不就又变成拿完速通票之后，
回来在速通票的队伍排队吗？
排不排队，
到底是普通票，
还是速通票，
不就没意义了吗？
当然,
人家迪士尼早就想过这些问题了。
所以,
为什么我觉得，
其实速通票并不仅仅只是一张券的问题，
它是一个系统的问题，
是一个机制的问题。
我们就在这个系统当中，
随便挑几个有意思的来给大家解释解释。
首先,
是速通票发放数量的问题。
我们刚才讲了，
如果你一位的发放，
最终又变成所有人在排队等待了。
不过确实，
迪士尼从来没有对外公布过，
这个速通票到底发放了多少，
或者说跟普通队伍的一个比例是怎么样的。
那这个不就跟现在付费的优速同是一样的吗？
迪士尼号称是严格控制数量的，
但是实际是多少，
没有人知道。
不过anyway,。
我们回归到当时的这个速通票，
即便迪士尼没有对外公布发放了多少速通票的数量，
但是,
它有一个规则，
你一次只能身上存在着一张速通票，
除非这个速通票核销了，
或者做费了。
啥意思？
比如说，
你拿了一个飞越地平线的速通票，
告诉你两点到三点来玩，
在此之前，
你是不能拿其他项目的速通票打。
如果说两点到三点，
你过来了，玩完了，
OK,
你可以再领下一张，
或者说两点到三点，
你没感得急，
来做，来玩，
那这张票做费了，
这个时候，
你可以再领。
如果说控制数量，
它是一个安排不公布的，
就没有人知道它发放了多少，
但是,
控制单位时段内，
你能个人获得的一个速通票的数量，
这个就是个名牌，
确实是可以控制过量的，
就是大家都能够明显的感知到说，
哦,是,
我只能拿一张。
那么,
除此之外，
第二个有意思的是，
每个项目的速通票机器，
都是数字化连接电脑的，
这个人家很早就在做数字化这个事情了，
那这个电脑在经过复杂的计算之后，
可以实时在普通对立，
就我们正常人没有速通票，
没有领到速通票的那个队伍里面，
看到等待时间，
那这个时间，
其实是已经算上了，
拿到速通票的人群的，
这么一个等待时间了。
但,
那同时呢，
这个电脑也会实时的计算出，
领速通票的人，
具体是在哪个时间窗口，
回来玩，
而这个时间窗口，
也是经过复杂计算的，
他也会去考虑说，
哎，有多少人排在普通队伍，
普通队伍啊，
所以他才会计算出来，
这个两点到三点，
而不是一点到两点，
因为现在普通队伍上面，
排队的人有很多。
所以啊，
这就是为什么，
我们说，
其实速通票的本质，
并不是说谁有优先权，
它的本质，
依旧是大家在一起排队，
只是有些人是要站着排队，
有些人是可以到处跑，
排队的。
那么这件事情，
它就不会造成一个，
不公平的事情，
因为所有人，
都是在一个排队系统当中，
排队的。
那么最后呢，
在这个系统当中，
还有一个比较有意思的东西，
就是我不知道，
买过付费的这个优速通的小伙伴，
或者说普通排队，
被优速通切入的小伙伴，
有没有印象啊，
其实优速通的队伍，
跟普通排队的队伍，
最后会会聚在一起的，
这个专业术，
叫做merge point,。
会合点，
那在这个会合点呢，
到底谁先上，
谁后上，
是会合点的员工说的算的，
那这个就需要员工有很强的，
这种激动性和现场调节能力了，
不过,
这些员工都是经过专业培训的，
而且迪士尼内部呢，
至少在当时那个年代，
是有四比一的一个官方说法的，
是放四个速通票的人，
然后呢，
再放一个普通队伍的人，
所以通过这种形式，
它也能够更好的去控制人流量。
那anyway,。
回到正题，
正是犹豫这个速通票，
FastPass这一套系统，
考虑的非常周到，
在1992年推出之后呢，
就非常成功，
甚至在一年后的2000年，
获得了佛罗里达工程协会颁布的一个奖项，
而且这一套FastPass，
就速通票的系统，
也获得了专利，
是人家的一个秘密，
随我们才说嘛，
就是你一张票，
肯定不能获得专利，
但是你背后是有这么一个排队管理系统的，
才能获得这个专利。
那当然呢，
如果我们话说回头来，
速通票也不是完全没有问题的，
最大的问题是啥，
就是游客的教育成本，
实在是太高了，
这是一个巨大的学习曲线，
即便迪士尼乐园做了大量的宣传，
但是还是有非常多的游客，
是不能够理解这个速通票的机制的。
就我们刚讲了那么一系列复杂的东西，
可能,
游戏小伙伴还不一定理解的。
那你想想那个时候，
也是互联网刚开始普及没多久的时候，
也不可能像现在一样，
你能在小红书上面，
抖音上面，
能看到大量的功率，
所以这种不理解，
就造成了消费者的愤怒，
为什么有人能插队？
你如果不仔细深究，
确实是想不清楚的。
因为,
我们现在知道了，
实际上你领了速通票的人，
也是在排队，
只是他们不需要物理的站在那里排队而已。
就像你在餐厅门口排队，
你发现只有30个人，
但是实际上前面有50个人领了号，
因为其他20个人在别的地方，
一边逛一边等。
而除此之外，
我们刚也说了嘛，
在项目门口显示的排队时间，
实际上是已经算了，
是已经领取速通票的人的时间的。
但是,
这些游客不理解，
只能看到有人插队。
即便你是先明白了。
这个速通票的机制，
但是你第一次去，
你也不知道哪个项目热门，
哪个项目，
应该先去拿速通票。
所以,
其实只有真的懂行的，
去过不止一次的游客，
才会给这个速通票系统，
非常高的评价。
那么,
除了这个游客教育成本太高以外，
另外一个问题也浮现了，
就是速通票，
开始给的过多了。
原来只有几个项目，
它会开启速通票机制，
后来为了满足不断增加的游客需求，
同时为了不让人去排队，
去消费，
也就逐步开启了更多的项目，
来发放这个速通票。
甚至后面还改了规则，
原来你的身上只能吃有一张，
我们刚刚不是讲了，
除非它核销或者作废，
你才能领下一张。
那后来呢，
又变成了，
在你拿了第一张，
速通票的两个小时之后，
就可以领第二张了。
你身上同时可以拥有两张。
你看,
速通票系统开始失控了吧。
如果速通票能控制好量，
实际上正如我们前面所说，
是能够很好的管理客流量的，
让游客能够较少的站着排队，
能够玩上更多的项目。
但是一旦速通票失控，
说的极端点，
如果每个人都可以领，
那就等同于没有人可以领得到。
那在当时一些火热的项目，
领取速通票的机器，
也要开始排队了，
人们在排队领着不用排队的门票，
你说这个事情有多讽刺，
这就是为什么？
我们说，
这个东西一旦失控，
就可能会引发一系列不好的猎缩反应。
所以我们想想，
现在的付费的这个优速通，对不对？
李士尼乐园，
依然是号称他是有限额的，
但是他也没有对外公布，
这个限额到底是多少，
他从来也没有在他的财报当中，
去公示这件事情，
那他会不会也走上这条路呢？
因为我解放了，
时间才能够带来更多的消费，
我解放更多的人，
更多的人就有了更多的时间消费，
所以我觉得这个担忧不是空穴来风的，
当然我们可以选择相信李士尼乐园，
但是这是一定存在担忧的，
因为这个事情就是一个黑箱子，
除了内部的人，
没有人，
实际上知道他发放了多少的速通票，
或者说现在的优速通。
当然,
就是在当时那个年代，
李士尼也很快地意识到了这个问题，
所以在发现问题之后，
又开始大量的减少发放，
只是这种反复也造成了游客的体验不假。
不过嘛，至少到现在，
这个速通票呢，
还只是揭露了游客之间的信息差的问题，
知道的会用，
熟悉的用的好，
不知道的会抱怨，
但整体的体验还是比较偏正向的，
他也不需要你花钱去买，
他也没有真正的赤裸裸的暴露出阶级差。
而接下去，
新的商业化的转折出现了，
游客可以花钱买时间了。
2008年,
李士尼启动了一个价值10亿美元的数字化项目，
叫做Next Generation,。
下一代项目，
目的是为了让游客有更好的体验的同时，
能够更合理地操控游客的流向，
还能再提升游客的整体消费，
听起来野心满满。
这个项目当中，
其中有个产品叫做Magic Band，
魔法手环，
它核心就是在手环里面搞一个芯片，
游客可以通过芯片进入乐园，
打开酒店的房门，兑换速通票，
甚至支付消费，
尤其是支付消费，
这种手环刷一下就能消费的形式，
是非常容易产生冲动消费的，
你不用在那儿掏钱包，
找卡签字，
我们说嘛，
付款越无感，
人就越容易花钱，
这是一个项目。
那么另外一个产品，
叫做Magic Plus,。
是一个手机的app，
游客可以通过这个app，
去查看地图，
查看演出时间，
玩小游戏，
查看等待时间等等一系列的事情，
这个看似是个提升游客体验的这么一个产品，
但是背后实际上又是一个人流排队管理的工具，
因为迪士尼乐园当时意识到了，
如果游客通过这个app，
看到乐园的另一头的项目排队时间过长，
它可能会放弃排队，
这就有操作空间了。
所以后来app上线的时候，
我看到一个说法是说，
迪士尼乐园会故意调高项目的，
显示的等待时间，
比如说真实预估的等待时间是60分钟，
迪士尼会把它调成90分钟，
目的就是阻止更多游客用过去排队。
同时,
这么做还有另外一个好处，
因为游客实际就只等待了60分钟，
比官方显示的90分钟要更短，
它反倒觉得很开心，
这就是为什么说，
这个数字化的项目，
其实是能够帮助迪士尼实现多重目标的。
但是,
这跟排队要花钱有什么关系呢？
那么在这个next generation的项目当中，
有一个子板块，
就是要改造现有的苏同票fastpass，
升级成了一个fastpass plus跟maxpass的服务。
你听听这些乱七八糟的不同的服务，
有多复杂，
这么多不同的东西叠在一起，
普通的游客是真的很难理解清楚这一套规则的。
那么,
我们稍微简单说一下，
这两个乱七八糟的东西，
第一个就是fastpass plus，
简单来说，
就是订了票之后，
所有的游客可以提前30天，
在线上去抢热门项目的苏同票。
这个目的是为了让更多游客都能够用上这个苏同票，
因为原来就是如果你没有所有线上话的时候，
有很多游客其实是不知道这些消息的，
他等到了圆区，
可能都不知道什么是苏同票，
但是你现在当你线上去买了这个票之后，
他会立刻提示你去抢这个苏同票，
所以很多人就知道有这么一个东西了，
那这个就是为了让更多的游客都能够利用上苏同票的方式，
利用上苏同票的这么一个系统。
但是不一样的是，
如果你是住迪士尼酒店的游客，
你可以提前60天去抢这个热门项目的苏同票。
虽然依旧是要抢，
就跟这个天猫双十一抢确是一样的，
但是住酒店的游客，
就可以比普通游客更早30天去抢。
当时迪士尼官方的说法是什么呢？
是说,
因为你住酒店，
你可能是远道而来的，
所以我为了让这些远道而来的游客，
有更好的这种假期体验，
我就给他们开放更早的，
更多的时间来去抢热门项目的苏同票。
这个时候就会有很多小伙伴存疑了，
对不对？
迪士尼怎么做到底是为啥呢？
是不是为了让更多的游客去订他的酒店？
因为你毕竟住酒店，
就比起普通游客，
有更多的时间来去抢热门项目的苏同票。
所以为了严谨一点点，
我也去看了一下迪士尼乐园，
在Fast Plus上线前的一个酒店入住率，
大概是在80%左右，
其实已经是非常高的了，
所以我觉得，
就个人觉得，
这在一定程度上面，
可能可以说明Fast Plus Plus，
给到住店游客，
更早的预约的这个动作，
对于酒店入住率的提升，
理论上是有限的，
因为如果说入住率是5%，
那可能更早预约这件事情，
会有很大的帮助，
但是你已经80%的入住率了，
想要到90%，
可能不是仅仅靠着Fast Plus Plus，
就能做到的。
但即便如此，
就是住酒店，
多付钱的游客，
就可以更早抢，
不管原因为何，
这个阶级差，
其实已经体现出来了。
而另外，
更激进的一个服务，
就是MaxPass,。
这是一个真真正正，
把时间商品化的一个服务了。
本来大家进入远区的时候，
是要走到项目入口的那个机器上面，
去领取苏同票的嘛，
而MaxPass,。
是在App端有这么一个服务，
可以让游客在入园之后，
立刻直接在手机上面抢，
不需要大老远，
走到项目门口去。
只是这个抢，
也是有门看到，
你是要花10块钱美金，
来买这个抢票权的，
当然这个10块钱美金，
不是抢一次票10块美金，
而是抢一天，
让你在这一天之内，
都拥有这个抢票权，
是要花10块钱美金的。
那这个时候，
你听出端倪了吗？
你买的是抢票权，
什么意思？
因为即便有了这个权利，
它不保证你一定能抢到，
自己喜欢的十段的票，
甚至不保证你一定能抢到票，
如果你真的没抢到票，
那这个10块钱也是不退的，
就很像机场的贵宾休息室，
有的贵宾休息室，
是可以单独买的，
即便你做的时间机场，
你也可以去买它的贵宾休息室的，
使用权，
而当你花了这个钱，
发现进去没有座位，
那你也只能站着等，
因为你买的并不是座位，
这就是MaxPass的抢票权的逻辑，
它没有Garantee，没有保证，
而且MaxPass刚上线的时候，
定价是10美元每天，
到了两年后，
涨到了15美元每天，
再后来涨到了20，
那大家这么停下来，
你为什么非要收钱呢？
原来的那种苏通票，
FastPass的机制不是挺好的吗？
当然,
一个企业想怎么做，
只要不违法，
它都可以嘛，对不对？
但是究其根本，
原因是说，
在2013年,
数字化的一些产品，
上线了之后，
出现了大量的问题，
比如说，
魔法手还了这个芯片，
它读取不出来，
远区信号不好，
WiFi也不稳定，
App也老是崩溃，
FastPass,。
这个苏东票的数据错误，
等等等等，
一系列的问题，
本来是用来提升用户体验的。
Next Generation的项目,。
反倒,
在2013年,
数字化的一些产品，
上线了之后，
出现了大量的问题，
比如说，
魔法手还了这个芯片，
它读取不出来，
让用户糟性，
体验差了，
也就不会再来了，
但是这个10亿美元，
我已经花出去了，
我不能打水漂，
那怎么办呢？
所以,
时间商品化这条路，
或许是它不得不走的一条路，
但是这样的时间商品化，
看起来，
其实是有问题的，
我们依旧不从道德角度，
而是从商业逻辑出发，
假设我园区里面，
一共只有20个项目，
本来有10个项目，
已经在免费发放苏东票了，
现在我升级了，
FastPass Plus,。
能让住店的游客，
有更多的优先选择权，
FastPass,。
又让部分游客，
可以花钱抢票，
那这些人是多花了钱的金主，
为了保证他们玩得开心，
我不要给他们更多的。
苏东票的配额吗？
是不是，
虽然说FastPass，
不能保证你一定能抢到，
但是我也不能太过分吧，
如果所有人都花了钱，
发现这个对吧，
还有80%人都抢不到，
那怎么办呢？
那同时呢，
就是迪士尼呢，
又想做好人，
我也想让普通游客的体验也好，
我也不能减少他们在线下。
拿到苏东票的这种几率吗？
那鱼和熊掌，
他都想坚得，
怎么办？
所以历史轮回，
这不就又走上了
当年苏东票一度失控的老路吗？
为了提升每个个体的体验，
我只能开放更多的苏东票项目，
从10个,
开到15个，
一些本来不用排队的那些冷门项目，
我也搞苏东票，
甚至连烟花观看区，
和迪士尼角色的这个路上见面，
花车巡验区，
等等等等这些，
本来是没有排队逻辑的项目，
它也加入到了新的苏东票系统当中，
这就是人为的在扩大，
苏东票的数量了，
而苏东票这个膨然巨物，
就开始变大了，
发了更多的苏东票，
大家体验好了一些，
就有更多的人来了，
或者来得更频繁了，
那我就继续多发，
这个膨然巨物就越滚越大了，
但是别忘了，
设施项目的承载量，
就只有这么大呀，
当到达某个临界点了，
体验就可能不再美丽了，
那怎么办呢？
不知道是幸运还是不幸运呢？
2020年这个疫情来临了，
那当然呢，
不幸在于毫无疑问嘛，
全球范围内的迪士尼乐园都受到了重挫，
甚至有些完全避愿，
很长一段的时间，
而幸运在于，
这留给了迪士尼乐园机会，
推出新的世界商品，
2021年,
美国的很多乐园重新开源之后，
全面的解除了原来的苏东票体系，
包括免费的线下领区，
也包括Fastpass Plus,。
也包括MaxPass，
取而代之的是推出了Lightning Lane，
基本上和上海迪士尼的优速通一样，
但是呢，
还不完全一样，
这个我们之后再说。
不过anyway,。
至此,
免费苏东票的日子全面结束了，
至少在绝大多数的迪士尼乐园当中。
现在,
只要你花钱，
你就能够优先游玩项目设施。
而这个时间商品成功吗？
理论上，非常成功。
疫情前的2019年，
全球迪士尼的游客人次在1.56亿，
整体收入在262亿美元，
而疫情后推出的Lightning Lane之后，
每年的收入不断上涨，
到了2024年，
游客人次在1.4亿，
比2019年还少1600万，
但是收入已经达到了341亿，
比2019年涨了80亿。
虽然迪士尼乐园的财报很粗，
它没有详细的门票、餐饮之类的收入差分，
但是毫无疑问，整体来看，
迪士尼乐园相比起疫情前来的人数少了，
但是收入却增加了非常多，
而且财报里面有很明确的多次提到过，
收入增加的原因就是Lightning Lane。
你看看，
这还挺讽刺的。
如果我们回过头来看看迪士尼乐园收费的历史，
最早的这种门票加项目票机制，
是为了从不同财富阶级的游客身上赚到不一样的钱，
当然也是为了让大家都能基于自己的能力，
自由选择嘛。
接着，一票通出现了，
是为了消灭这种不同阶级的体感，
让所有人付同一个门票钱，
平等的排队。
再然后，免费的速通票出现，
也是为了不管阶级如何，
我希望所有人能够平等地玩到更多的项目，
提升体验而推出的。
然而，到了现在，
Lightning Lane的出现,。
次让迪士尼回到了最早开源的那一天，
阶级的折修部重新撕开了。
这就是迪士尼乐园排队管理和时间商品化的股市了。
当然,
美国的迪士尼乐园还是离我们比较远的，
我们转换视角来看看上海迪士尼乐园，
虽然都是迪士尼乐园，
但是上海和美国还是有区别的。
大家要知道，
上海迪士尼乐园是合资企业，
共同运营的，
其中迪士尼持股47%，
中资的上海深迪集团持股53%，
那么深迪集团的背景，
大家自己搜一搜，
我就不多说了。
而这种非迪士尼百分之百持股的结构，
其实也很正常，
香港的迪士尼也是合资，
东京的迪士尼就更夸张了，
迪士尼是没有股权的，
它只是把品牌授权给了其他公司，
来去建立跟运营，
因为毕竟建了一个乐园，
钱绝对不是小数目，
所以合资也很正常。
那么说回上海迪士尼，
上海迪士尼在2016年开源的时候，
也是采用的全球统一的。
这种免费速通票的系统大，
和美国最早的时候是一个逻辑，
但是仅仅在一年后的2017年，
上海迪士尼就推出了尊相卡，
也是我们俗称的优速通服务，
只要花钱就能够优先通过。
你看嘛，
美国迪士尼乐园是在疫情之后，
2021年推出的，
上迪其实还是美国迪士尼的老前辈，
当然最开始的时候，
其实也是混之来的，
就是你可以线下免费去领取，
这种不要钱的速通票，
当然你也可以花钱卖这个优速通。
我看到网上有很多说法，
说上海迪士尼是不得已搞付费的，
是因为免费的时候，
黄牛泛滥，
黄牛进入园区之后，
就会立刻跑去领这个速通票，
然后高价卖出。
那么关于这一点，
这个说法我是稍微有一点点存疑的，
因为第一个，
如果真是因为这个原因，
那你要么就直接取消免费的速通，
就直接转向付费的优速通就好了，
我没有必要在当时那个时期，
让两者混之来并存，
因为混之来让我听起来，
是有点想从免费到付费的这么一个试点，
或者说测试。
这是第一点，
那么第二点，
黄牛这种事情在美国也曾经出现过，
美国人也搞黄牛的，
而且人家玩的更花，
在美国的迪士尼乐园里面，
是有专门的残疾人的快速通道的，
当然上海也有，
只是美国的黄牛很夸张，
他们甚至会给游客雇一个残疾人，
然后普通游客跟着残疾人一组，
装成一个家庭，
进入快速通道。
但是后来，
随着实名制跟App的推出，
黄牛现象在很大程度上面就缓解了，
所以这就是第二个我不完全认同的原因，
就是一定会有比收费更好的这种手段，
打击黄牛，
因为美国的迪士尼，
人家也是搞了实名制跟推出的App，
这不就在一定程度上面，
可以去打击黄牛吗？
所以如果你告诉我，
搞付费是不得已，
就是因为黄牛，
我是完全不认同的，
当然是我个人观点。
那么anyway,。
就是我们继续说，
那么在疫情之后，
从2020年开始，
就没有免费的苏通票，
可以在线下领取了，
上海迪士尼还是非常积贼的，
我不是采疑朋友，
但确实至少美国的迪士尼乐园，
取消免费苏通票的时候，
还官宣了，
但是上海的迪士尼，
默默进行了这一切，
没有官方的说法。
而且另外一个很积贼的是什么呢？
还记得我们前面说的，
这种苏通票的本质吗？
其实是大家一起排队，
只是苏通票游客，
需要在一个时间窗口回来，
而这个时间窗口，
是纳入了普通人队伍，
排队时间综合考虑的，
也就是说，
大家都是在一个系统当中排队的，
只是普通的游客，
需要站着排队，
苏通票的游客，
可以逛着排队。
那么，美国的迪士尼，
在疫情之后推出的Lightning Lane，
虽然付费花钱，
但是依旧是买的时间窗口，
这个时间窗口，
依旧是纳入了，
预估普通人排队人数，
一起考虑的，
只是权重，
当然更倾向于付费游客了。
他到后面，
才推出了一个升级版，
就是没有时间窗口了，
你买了，
什么时候想来，
就可以来。
而上海的迪士尼，
一开始推出的游俗通，
就是没有时间窗口的，
你买了，
什么时候想来，
就可以来玩。
那为什么这件事情这么重要呢？
我非提不可呢？
当然,
这个纯属个人观点，
有时间窗口，
意味着什么？
其实意味着，
我还是在和普通人，
对立,
一起排队。
我花钱买的，
实际上，
是一个我可以，
不用站着排队的权利。
我其实买的是，
解放自己排队的权利。
但是,
没有时间窗口，
就意味着，
我可能不是在和普通队伍，
一起排队了。
因为我想什么时候去，
就什么时候去，
这就意味着，
有一点点，
花了钱，
买别人时间的意味了。
那当然，
因为游俗通呢，
本来就是限制售卖的，
这个是迪士尼的官方说法，
所以我才说，
有一点点这个意味，
如果不限制售卖，
那才是完全花钱，
买别人的时间。
不过这个晚点在聊，
所以呢，
到现在，
2016年,
免费的苏东票，
早就已经消失在，
上海迪士尼当中了，
取而代之的，
就是这种，
各种各样的，
额外付费的产品。
而在这些产品当中，
一个比较有意思的观察，
大家如果感兴趣，
可以下载一个，
上海迪士尼的app，
我在上面看了一下，
所有售卖的产品，
里面分门别类，
其实还蛮多的，
但是我自己觉得，
比较有意思，
是两种，
一种是早想看，
可以提前一个小时入员，
这就是非常时间商品化的，对不对？
而且这个量化，
非常具体，
你的一个小时的时间，
价值就是199，
那是果真如此吗？
我就查了一下，
上海平均公司，
如果我们按照，
双修每天工作，
8小时来算的话，
在上海，
一个小时，
平均能赚72块钱，
等于说，
你要工作3个小时，
才能够，
攒购钱，
提早一个小时入员，
那当然，
这个计算呢，
这是just for fun,。
那么,
回到正题，
除了这个早想卡以外，
另外一种，
我觉得比较有意思的产品，
就是优速通了，
那当然，
优速通，
可以每个项目，
每个项目的买，
就是你单独买，
那么项目和项目之间的价格，
也有差异，
很正常，
热门项目，
就是要贵些，
可以理解，
但是,
除了单独项目以外，
上海,
还会卖优速通的套票，
有三项的，
六项的，
八项的等等，
那为什么会有套票呢？
这是划算吗？
确实,
套票更划算，
比起你每个项目单独购买，
但是,
如果你仔细看看，
这些项目套票当中的，
项目的排列组合，
是很有意思的，
比如说，
三项的这个套餐，
它绝对不会在套票里面，
一次包含三个热门项目，
一定是两个热门项目，
加一个冷门项目，
那为什么这么干？
我们不能就包含
三个热门的项目，
然后定价呢，
比起这个两个热门的，
加一个冷门的，
当然可以，
但是一方面，
如果太贵，
那有些人就不会考虑买套票了，
这种热门加冷门的组合呢，
能够降低一点点，
价格的门看，
那么另外一方面，
我觉得，
本质上，
它还是在想，
通过套票的这个形式，
去做人流排队管理嘛，
对不对，
你买都买了这个套票，
冷门的那个项目，
虽然是冷门的，
那我还是去玩吧，
那这样子，
迪士尼就能够，
更好的去分散这个人流，
但当然，
纯属我的猜测，
不是结论，
那么这个呢，
就是上海迪士尼，
从免费速通票，
到付费优速通的这个历史了，
那,
说到此，
我觉得，
商业的部分，
我们就聊完了，
对于,
到底迪士尼，
从商业的角度，
是不是，
应该要推出，
这种优速通的形式，
大家可以自己想一想，
那我想接着，
换个视角，
不从商业的角度，
去聊聊，
优速通怎么，
最大化迪士尼的收益的，
从社会视角，
来聊聊优速通，
我们回到一开始，
我们说的父亲，
为什么优速通，
会让他崩溃呢，
表面上其实很简单，
因为排了三个小时，
因为他不公平，
因为有人花钱买差队，
而再往下钻一层，
很扎心的是，
这是因为，
人的阶级，
被两条队伍，
给分开了，
有钱人，
跟普通人，
但,
更核心，
更核心的是什么呢，
是这种阶级，
被看见了呀，
这个父亲亲眼，
看见花了钱的人，
不用排队，
他呢,
也在被花了钱的人看着，
甚至更刺痛的是，
可能他们看都不看，
这位父亲眼，
对方只是非常自然的，
理所当然的，
从他旁边走过去，
这就会制造一种，
很强烈的心理落差，
在没有速通票的时代，
大家都买同样的门票，
价格是一样的嘛，
排同样的队伍，
阶级不阶级的，
至少物理空间上面是平等的，
心理上面是安全的，
而付费优速通的出现，
就是明明白白再告诉你，
你和他们，
是不一样的，
不过呢，
只想到这里呢，
我觉得其实还是不够的，
因为在我们生活当中，
到处都有这种，
被看见的阶级分层嘛，
那,
飞机有头洞舱，
商务舱，
银行有VIP窗口，
医院还有更贵的专家号呢，
酒店还有行政走廊呢，
这些都能被看见呀，
但是为什么，
他们通常不会，
像迪士尼的优速通那个样子，
会让人产生一种，
非常具体的，
非常及实的，
然后甚至是有些，
羞辱性的这种愤怒，
可能更值得讨论的是，
不是有没有阶级差，
这是废话啊，
因为现在消费社会，
怎么会没有阶级差呢，对吧，
甚至也不只是，
我们要去讨论阶级差，
有没有被看见，
而是为什么，
有些阶级差，
即使被看见了，
也会被接受为规则，
而迪士尼乐园的阶级差，
在被看见的时候，
就会让人感受，
成一种受伤害，
那,
为了回答这个问题，
我们还是先说说，
排队这个事情，
那我在网上，
看到很多小伙伴，
试图把迪士尼远区，
优速通的排队，
这个可以被看见的，
阶级差，
和其他的这种，
排队特权做对比，
比如说，
我们刚刚说的，
飞机的头等舱，
商务舱有限排队，
银行VIP窗口，
可以有限办理，
酒吧的低销包台，
餐厅的低销包间，
可以提前定位置，
或者说，
不用排队，
直接进去，
等等等等，
那他们会argy说，
如果你去迪士尼乐园排队，
会因为看到，
阶级差而崩溃，
是一个不常见的事情，
但是,
这种排队类比，
是不太准确的，
虽然都是排队，
但是排队背后的价值，
是不一样的，
朋友们，
我们要想想，
普通游客，
花钱在迪士尼乐园，
买的到底是什么，
有些人说，
开心快乐，
那,
直接和开心快乐，
挂钩的是啥？
当然,
整体的氛围，
服务,
项目好不好玩，
也很重要，
但是最直接的，
和最重要的，
还是玩了多少项目，
那,
玩了多少项目，
很简单，
不就是等待时间吗？
所以,
本质上，
你花钱，
在迪士尼乐园，
买的,
就是时间，
而这个时间，
大家不要以为，
只是一天，
从开源的8点半，
到必远的晚上9点半的，
这13个小时，
很多游客，
是从外地来的，
高铁,
飞机,
请假,
带孩子，
做功率，
这些时间，
虽然没有被，
算在票价里面，
但是,
这也是为了，
这13个小时，
一天,
在迪士尼里面，
时间的价值，
本身就是特别高的，
迪士尼的一个小时，
是被放大的一个小时，
那当然，
这是从游客的视角来看待的，
如果说，
从迪士尼规则的视角来看待，
我不知道，
大家有没有仔细地，
研究过，
迪士尼的门票，
人家是很清楚的，
边界给划分出来的，
如果你真的，
认真地，
去研究一下，
上海迪士尼乐园的规则，
在游客虚之里面，
有一句话，
在乐园的，
一天运营时间内，
游客可能无法体验，
所有游乐项目。
这句话，
本质上，
就是告诉你，
从法律和合同的层面来说，
你买的是一个，
进入远区的权利，
它并不保证游玩，
你没有一个，
被保证的游玩权利。
所以其实，
普通游客，
认为我买的是时间，
来做这些项目，
但是商业上面来说，
迪士尼销售的时间产品，
针对的对象，
只是那些优速通的游客，
它不是针对普通游客的，
甚至买了优速通的游客，
也不是百分之百保证的，
因为优速通的条款里面，
也是有一个disclaimer的。
Anyway,
回到排队价值这件事情上，
这就是为什么，
迪士尼里的等待，
和其他成绩里面的等待，
是不一样的，
虽然头等舱，
商务舱可以优先排队，
但是优先排队，
只是整个服务包的，
一个小部分而已，
服务的价值，
还包含了，
更好的餐食，
更大的空间，
休息室等等，
而且说实话，
优先登机，
才能够耽误你多少时间，
10分钟,
15分钟,
而且飞机的主要价值，
是从ad更快速的，
到bd。
再比如说，
银行VIP的窗口，
像是招行的金会花卡，
对吧,
但是Again,。
去银行的主要目的，
是为了要办事情，
事情解决了，
才是最重要的。
所以这就是为什么，
现在银行的线上app，
能够办理很多业务，
那即便你一定要去线下，
银行的线下网点，
其实也是很多的，
这一家要排队，
我再换一家，
除非我今天非办不可，
不然实在不行，
我明天在提早点来，
不是也可以吗？
所以你看，
在银行排队当中，
时间的价值，
其实确实是比，
头等舱，
商务舱的时间价值，
更大的，
但是,
最大的价值，
其实还是办事情，
而且有很多，
被选的方案，
可以供你选择，
所以它在很大的程度上，
就会消解掉，
这种时间价值。
那么,
正是因为这些类柄，
对象当中，
它的时间价值，
跟迪士尼的时间价值，
是不等值的，
所以,
这就很好理解了，
为什么在迪士尼乐园，
等了三个小时之后，
附近会愤怒。
那么,
再进一步说，
迪士尼乐园的排队，
不仅仅是时间价值的本身，
当你的时间，
让度给别人的时候，
你就会更愤怒了，
这就涉及到
很有意思的事情了，
叫做,
增量特权，
跟挤站特权，
什么叫增量特权？
比如说，
我和一个
漂亮的小姐姐朋友，
一起去喝咖啡，
坐下没多久，
服务员小哥，
就送上了一杯咖啡，
说是免费送给小姐姐的，
这杯咖啡，
就是一种增量特权，
因为小姐姐长得好看，
获得了额外的好处，
但是我会因此不开心吗？
不会啊，
如果我和一个帅哥朋友，
一起去喝咖啡，
坐下去没多久，
服务员小姐姐，
送给她一杯这个免费的咖啡，
我会因此而不开心吗？
也不太会，
我顶多心理低估几句，
或者说开个玩笑说，
长得帅就是好，
对吧,
但是,
如果今天，
服务员在给帅哥朋友，
送完咖啡之后，
轮到给我点难的时候，
非常不耐烦，
与其很差，
还翻白眼，
这个时候，
我就会生气了，
而这个生气的对象，
不是我的朋友，
是这个服务员，
因为我们都是顾客，
我们应该被平等的接待，
如果你只是多送我朋友一杯咖啡，
这种增量特权，
我完全可以接受，
但是如果你对我态度差，
是因为认为我没有朋友帅，
这种增量特权，
就会被理解成一种，
几战特权，
当然,
人家帅和罪子只有，
对不对，
所以我愤怒的对象，
不会是我的朋友，
而是那个区别对待的人，
而回到商业的视角，
这个道理是一样的，
比如说，
飞机的头等舱，
跟商务舱，
航空公司给头等舱，
更大的作用，
更好的餐饰，
更好的服务，
这是人家花钱买的，
这种更好的服务，
不会让你产生一种，
发美舒服一分钟，
我就更难受一分钟的感觉，
所以,
这个就更接近于增量特权，
这里的有钱，
能够买这种服务，
本质上不就是我朋友的帅吗，
对不对，
但是你花的钱，
其实并没有影响我，
不会让我不舒服，
但是优速通，
它更接近于，
一种几战特权，
因为一个项目，
每一小时接待的人数，
是有限的，
如果一部分的容量，
给了优速通，
那普通队伍得到的容量，
就会减少，
优速通，
可是在旁边开了一个新项目，
它是在同一个项目，
同一个容量吞吐系统里面，
重新去分配你进入的顺序，
所以,
普通游客会本能的感觉到，
它快,
是因为我们，
我们是因为它快，
这句话特别重要，
很多特权，
之所以没有那么刺痛人，
是因为它看起来，
是它多得了，
而不是我少得了，
但优速通的问题是，
它特别容易被理解成，
它多得的那部分，
我少得的那部分，
不过,
如果我们从理性层面，
来讨论这个问题，
就是,
这个小伙伴们，
如果都理解清楚了，
我们前面说的，
这种速通票的原理，
我们会知道，
速通票在不耐用的情况下，
其实,
本质上，
是为了更好的匹配，
这种需求跟供给，
减少物理性质的排队，
让你一边逛一边等，
提高整个圆区的，
运行效率，
让消费者的体验，
整体提升，
不管你是免费的，
还是付费的，
如果取消了，
这个速通票的系统，
很可能导致，
大家都一窝蜂地，
去排热门项目，
没人在外面逛，
队伍会显得更长，
反倒会让大家玩的项目更少，
而且,
确实,
我们前面提到过，
就是,
普通队伍入口显示的那个等待时长，
是已经考虑了，
付费的优速通的数量，
从而进行估算的，
对吧,
那这个，
当然,
很多人是不理解的，
我们今天也是解释过了，
可能很多，
听众小伙伴们才理解，
对吧,
所以,
人知道速通的意义，
和理性思考的前提下，
在你等待的三个小时，
毁酸，天热，
孩子哭，
旁边的优速通，
还在一批一批的，
这个往里面涌入的时候，
你真的能保持冷静吗？
对不对，
所以,
即便你知道了规则，
就先别提大家不知道规则，
不理解这个原理，
但你即便理解了这个规则，
理解这个原理，
你就能保持冷静吗？
可能,
也未必，
如果我们再往下探，
当人的这种体感，
压过理性的时候，
会开始追问规则的公平性了，
对不对？
虽然你是多花钱，
但是却侵占了我的时间，
这个公平吗？
当然,
我不是说，
花钱买时间这件事情，
本身就不公平，
我也没有那么理想主义，
那么难意，
因为,
现代的商业社会，
本来就是分层的，
你花更多的钱，
获得更多的服务，
这没有什么奇怪的，
但真正的问题是，
敌视你这个规则制定者，
有没有办法，
让所有人，
更合理地，
感受到公平？
因为,
优速通卖的，
是一个对列系统里面的优先顺序，
这个概念，
不是那么容易被理解的，
所以对于迪士尼来说，
公平问题，
就会变得更复杂了，
我们可能要拆解几个不同的公平，
来去看一看，
那么首先第一层，
是程序公平，
迪士尼乐园，
有没有这么一套，
花钱买时间的清晰规则？
很显然，
这个答案肯定是有的嘛，
对不对？
但是问题是，
做得够不够？
迪士尼乐园，
有没有进到最大的可能，
让所有人都理解这套规则？
确实,
有不少人，
是通过app下单，
下订单的，对不对？
所以他可以看到不同的服务套餐，
但是,
还有很多人，
是通过非诛，
协成,
代订等等订票的，
他们真的百分之百，
知道这套规则吗？
而且,
很多游客，
确实没有那么多时间，
去做详细的攻略，
即便做了攻略，
真的能对规则理解到位吗？
即使普通的游客，
知道有优速通，
也不等于，
真的理解了，
优速通对普通的影响，
很多游客，
可能只是知道，
有人可以花钱快一点，
但他未必知道，
快一点，
会在我排队三个小时后，
还不断的在我旁边打断我，
这个是他没有预期的，
同时,
迪士尼的规则，
也是来回变的，
你想想，
上海迪士尼，
刚开始，
还有免费的速通票，
后来推出，
付费的优速通，
和免费速通票，
混着来，
再后来，
又默默的，
取消了免费速通票，
全都没有，
如果你现在去，
上海迪士尼的app，
还能看到一个叫做，
预约等候卡的，
一个小图标，
小icon,
你点进去，
可以看到，
他有一个链接，
是可以看到，
这个叫做，
预约等候卡的规则的，
那这个东西是个啥，
预约等候卡，
我看了看，
详细看了它的规则，
这个看起来，
就是一个，
线上免费，
速通票领取的，
这么一个东西，
但是,
实际上，
现在,
这么一个，
预约等候卡，
已经,
什么都预约不了了，
我自己在app上面，
操作过，
而且,
应该也不是我一个人，
小红书上面，
很多人都说，
实际上，
什么都预约不了，
那如果真的如此，
你为什么，
还要留在你的app当中呢，
你放在那，
不就是，
让人非常confusing了吗？
那当然，
也有小伙伴说，
规则就在那里，
你不去看，
你找不到怪谁，
我完全可以理解，
我也不是要杠啊，
就是不要分对错，
而是要试图理解，
为什么会有，
这种不公平的，
因为,
很多时候，
不公平感，
不是因为规则不存在，
而是因为规则存在，
但是,
普通人理解规则，
掌握规则，
利用规则的成本，
实在是太高了，
就像很多淘宝商家，
在这个商品详信业里面，
他前几张图，
都会把产品吹得天花乱坠，
但是,
在最后一张图上面，
有一行小字，
注意事项，
放在最后一页，
往往消费者，
就被骗，
打一行都骗，
被骗入坑了，
这不就是，
anyway,
这个第一层，
程序公平，
由于真的难以，
百分百，
让优客都清楚的，
深刻地理解，
这个所谓优素通的规则，
所以,
造成了这种不公平感，
那么第二层呢，
实际上是特权公平，
因为我看到很多人说，
说这个能花钱，
就是最大的公平了，
所以他们不能理解，
为什么没花钱，
你还能嚷嚷这要公平？
但是我们深想一层，
你花了钱，
就是真的公平吗？
迪士尼乐园，
造成优素通是有限额的，
但是它也从来没有公开，
公布过这个比例，
我可以理解，
高峰期低谷期的，
客有量是不一样的嘛，
所以这个比例，
你是要激动调整的，
很难你都每天的，
每天的这个精准预估，
这个我完全可以理解，
但是,
你为什么不公布，
历史数据呢？
你至少给一个大概的区间，
给所有的优客，
一个参考也可以嘛，
对不对？
如果你不公布，
就有可能造成，
黑箱子滥用，
我们前面提到了，
免费的，
费的速通票历史上，
也出现过这种情况啊，
虽然是不用花钱的，
今天你花钱，
只要排15分钟，
明天花一样的钱，
要排30分钟，
你觉得这个公平吗？
所以当你理解，
特权可能也未必公平的时候，
我觉得你可能就可以，
更好地去理解，
普通优客的这种情绪了，
那,
普通优客也是一样的嘛，
对吧?
今年花了499，
排队了3个小时，
那么假设，
明年在同样的时间，
同样的客流量的情况下，
我花一样的钱，
因为,
迪士尼释出了更多的优速通，
所以我排队，
变成了5个小时了，
这公平吗？
那么有人呢，
也会说，
要不要就取消，
这个付费的优速通，
全部都改回免费的，
不就好了吗？
那当然，
你提这个观点的话，
迪士尼是要给你鸡眼的，
但是,
即便真的改回，
这个免费的速通票，
它公平吗？
如果一对夫妻，
推着儿童车进来，
如果身强力壮的年轻人，
有力气，
先冲到速通票机器前面，
这对于年长的人公平吗？
当然,
这个我不是要跟你抬杠，
我只是想说，
没有绝对公平这个概念，
所以不管怎么做，
资源存在稀缺性，
就需要分配，
那既然要分配，
就不可能出现绝对公平的，
只是,
迪士尼原来选择免费，
现在选择收费，
那这个收费呢，
和这个钱，
万额支援挂钩的之后，
就会放大这种不公平的感受，
而这种不公平，
最后呢，
就会让游客把情绪，
导向员工，
以及迪士尼乐园，
还记得我们前面说的这个，
服务员送咖啡的例子吗？
对吧,
我的愤怒其实不会导向，
与我的好朋友啊，
而是会导向服务员，
普通游客真正愤怒的对象，
也绝对不是优速通的游客，
反而是工作人员，
是迪士尼，
这是因为人对于不公平的感知，
最在意的，
是谁制定规则，
优速通游客在普通人眼里，
更像是使用规则的人，
而不是制造规则的人，
很多普通游客甚至会觉得说，
如果我有钱，
其实我可能也会买，
所以你看这个就很有意思对不对，
这种道德压力就会开始转移了，
真正被认为有责任的是，
设计系统的人，
设计规则的人，
游戏课金其实也是一个道理嘛，
其实玩家很少真正去恨那些课金玩家，
大家真正骂的是这个游戏公司，
因为所有人都知道，
是这个游戏公司，
这个系统先创造了，
不课金就痛苦，
就低人一等的这种结构，
那么迪士尼也是，
普通游客真正感受到的是，
这种系统故意让我们，
迪士尼故意让我们，
而优速通游客，
只是系统里面的受益者而已，
所以愤怒，
会开始从个人冲突，
变成这种结构性的问题，
大家讨论的不再是，
他为什么可以插队，
而是,
为什么一个童话世界，
可以公开收买时间，
所以你看这个事情，
其实很复杂的，
因为他把很多不同的要素，
叠加在一起了，
就第一，
他让结局插被看见了，
第二,
他发生在一个时间价值，
极高的场景里面，
第三,
他不是单纯的一个增量特权，
而是更像是挤占特权，
因为优速通不是新开一个项目，
而是在同一个吞吐系统里面，
重新进行分配顺序，
所以普通游客会感觉说，
我的卖是因为他的快，
所以这种阶级插被放大更多，
那么也就触发了第四点，
公平问题，
一旦觉得不公平，
你最后的愤怒，
就会流向迪士尼和员工，
当然,
我也不是在为这个父亲开拓，
先不论是否，
应该产生愤怒情绪，
比如说即便你产生了这个愤怒情绪，
也不应该直接把矛头指向工作人员，
对对,
何苦为难打工人，
这确实是需要反思的。
但是,
很多人说什么，
穷就待在家里，
没钱就别来，
这种特别赤裸裸的阶级升级，
至少我个人是不太喜欢的。
确实,
如果我们理性分析，
人家迪士尼就是一个商业化公司，
人家也要赚钱，
没有什么不能做的，
但是在那一刻，
人真的很难进行这么一场串的理性分析，
这个父亲就是在那一刻，
感觉情绪上头了，
突然snap了，
我自己也有过一次类似的情况出现，
我不知道大家知不知道，
麦当劳的麦香鱼，
其实是只有半片知识的，
我是真的从来没有关注过这件事情，
我甚至没有认知到这件事情，
因为宣传图上，
确实就是只拍了有那半片的角度，
所以我脑子里面老是觉得，
这里面的知识就是一整片，
不要问我为什么，
我也不知道为什么，
我就是这么认知的，
到今年有一次点，
我也不知道为什么，
我就把那个麦香鱼汉堡打开了，
发现只有半片，
然后我那天又特别饿，
一下子我这个火就上来了，
在小程序里面联系那个客服，
霹雳啪拉我打了一堆大堆的话，
然后拍了照片，
说你们就是这样子的吗，
你们会做品控吗，
你们麦当劳就是进入中国都多少年了，
怎么还会出现只有半片知识这个问题呢，
就一顿狂输出，
然后这个客服就一读之后，
很礼貌地回复说，
真的不好意思先生，
让你的体验差了，
但是我们麦香鱼呢，
一直都是只有半片知识的，
我听到这个话，
就不说听到这个话，
我看到这句话，
我心里面想你完蛋了，
你这是骗人，
你的照片上的角度看起来就是一片，
然后我就回到了那个点单的页面，
结果在最后麦香鱼产品的这个详情页当中，
确实看到配料表上面写着，
只包含半片知识，
人家确实说了，
那我还不自信，
因为我的记忆当中就是一整片，
但是我又找不到证明，
所以最后我只好问问你，
拆GBT老师，
这个拆GBT老师就告诉我说，
麦当劳1960年代，
在没进入中国之前设计的，
就是半片知识，
至少在麦香鱼产品当中，
是因为觉得说，
知识太多会抢了鱼的味道，
虽然没有公开的信息说明，
中国曾经有过一片的时代存在，
但是我猜想，
麦当劳是一个SOP很强的公司，
除了真的是这种
中国特别本土化的产品，
不然全球一样的这种产品，
它的标准理应是一致的，
所以理论上，
如果1960年代，
这个知识就是半片的，
那它进入到中国之后，
应该长久以来就是半片的，
我这么理性思考了之后，
我真的说不出话了，
然后回到客服那边，
跟客服道道个歉，
说不好意思，
确实是我没看清楚，
这就是一个突然，
有一个点，
我snap了,
就是我又饿，
然后又打开了那个汉堡，
看到半片知识，
我完全被情绪支配了，
这确实是不应该的，
那当然换一个角度，
我相信客服也一定挺委屈的，
所以迪士尼可能也很委屈，
那还能怎么办呢，
对不对，
只要客流量在，
只要热门的项目，
它的容量还是有限制的，
这个矛盾就会一直存在，
于是,
网上就出现了一个。
特别有意思的现象，
每个人，
网友们都摇身一变，
变成了迪士尼乐园的CEO，
开始讨论迪士尼乐园，
该怎么改了，
有些听起来甚至很有道理，
但是深究又不太站得住脚，
我调几个稍微说一说，
不过在说之前，
首先我想先把讨论的这些人群，
一刀切，
虽然这种一刀切不太对，
但是为了方便我们大家理解，
我就粗粗的一刀切吧，
一派是特权派，
不管是不是他买得起优俗通，
不管他会不会买优俗通，
但是他支持迪士尼商业化时间，
这一派我都算作特权派，
那么另外一方就是普通派了，
认为默许金钱能够买时间的迪士尼，
是在损害普通游客的利益，
他太过商业化了，
这是普通派，
那我们分别看看这些CEO们的观点，
首先是入员门票价格，
特权派跟普通派在这件事情上面，
出奇的意志，
提高入员门票价格，
特权派认为，
就是迪士尼本来就应该更贵，
迪士尼可以提高票价，
这样子就可以天然地过滤掉一批游客了，
普通派他就有点类似于赌气的类型，
他表达会更激进一些，
说你要不就定3000块钱一个人好了，
这样的话你就不用担心，
要服务那些买不起优速通的游客了，
你就专注你的这些愿意付费的游客就好了，
你不要两边都想讨好，
特权派是想迪士尼摔掉人，
普通派是想迪士尼选边站，
但是不管是什么角度，
两派都把涨价这件事情想得太简单了，
因为很多人会不自觉的觉得说，
哎，迪士尼现在这样是因为他不敢涨价，
只要涨价，人自然就少了，
但是我有几个反驳的点，
首先迪士尼本来就是动态定价的，
就是平日周末暑假五一十一春节，
这价格本来就不一样，
人家高峰日的票价本来也比平日的要贵几百块钱，
但是问题是五一十一人真的少了吗？
甚至很多时候越贵人越多，
因为对于很多游客来说，
真正决定出不出去玩的不是那个贵两百块钱，
而是我只有这个时间能来，
我只有五一十一，
我的老婆修价，
我的孩子修价，
我们全家修价，
对吗?
所以很多人会天然地以为说，
价格提高了，
人就变少了，
但这个在一定程度上是对的，
但是在现实时期里，
它其实没有那么那么的线性，
所以票价上涨，
当然会摔掉一部分人，
但也未必会像很多人想象当中那么有效，
而且甚至可能还会被骂，
你怎么突然涨价，
对不对？
所以怎么做都不是，
那我的第二个论点是，
其实很多人讨论的时候，
会默认为说，
把价格提上去，
摔掉普通游客，
是一种很自然的商业逻辑，
你迪士尼就是应该这么干嘛，对不对？
你就把他们摔一绕就好了，
但是问题是，
虽然没有详细的公开数据，
我依然相信理论上，
去迪士尼的游客，
是一个金字塔的结构，
就是真正高消费的那些人，
永远是少数人，
那么大部分去迪士尼的游客，
本来就是普通的游客，
本来就只会买普通门票，
这就跟航空公司是一样的，
做头动舱永远是少数人群，
你的演唱会VIP那场也是少数嘛，
虽然普通游客贡献的单人的消费，
肯定会比特权游客都要少，
但是真的要算下来，
你把基数乘以单人的消费，
这么算下的话，
其实你真的不知道，
总数到底哪一遍大，
所以问题，
从来都不是说，
为什么迪士尼不只服务有钱人，
而是他本来就不可能只服务有钱人，
就这种哪一衣服的说，
只服务有钱人就算了，
这种想法是不对的，
因为他整个商业模式，
就是建立在大量的普通游客，
加少量的高消费游客，
这种情绪结构下的，
他同时存在这两波游客，
都会给他贡献非常庞大的收益。
但当然，
我也不是说否定涨价这件事情，
只是对于迪士尼乐园来说，
这一定是需要一个非常详细，
复杂的模型来去利益，
最大化的嘛，对不对，
因为我们讲了嘛，
就是他是个商业公司，
我不是随便定出来的，
我肯定是仔细全衡了。
所有的种benefit跟cost之后，
为了要让我利益更大化，
我才定出来的，
他肯定不是一个说，
说调整就调整了这么一个状态，
所以这个是价格之争，
虽然大家都说，
两派都说要提升价格，
但其实上我是觉得，
不是说价格提升不合理，
而是比较难，
这么快的就能够提升价格，
以及说这么激进的提升价格，
接着我们来看看第二种方案，
或者说第二种论调，
是关于容量的，
这个方案主要是普通派的观点，
他们认为说，
迪士尼乐园卖出去的门票太多了，
你实际上根本容不下这么多人，
我前阵的刷斗银的时候，
还看到一个邮客分享说，
今年的五一去了十一万的邮客，
去迪士尼乐园，
但是上海迪士尼乐园的总容量，
才三万人，
超了两倍度，
所以他们认为说，
迪士尼要么就是应该限制人数，
不要搞那么多人，
要么你就是扩建，
现在你就是纯属的，
故意多卖票，
为了赚钱，
而这种多卖票，
让邮客的体验变差了，
肯定是会损害迪士尼长期利益的，
所以你们就不要，
现在卖这么多门票，
对吧,
就是忍一忍，
更长线的来去思考自己的收益问题，
这个方案听起来很有道理，
但是我可能还是要解释一下，
一些认知误区，
首先,
很多人听到，
我们刚刚提到，
十一万跟三万这个数字就炸毛了，
这里我要帮迪士尼证本倾援一下，
首先,
上海迪士尼，
是没有正式公布过，
他的邮客容量是多少的，
但是在2020年疫情的时候，
当时的迪士尼整体，
迪士尼家公司，
不是说迪士尼乐园，
而是迪士尼公司的CEO，
Bob Jepak,。
在财报电话会议上，
其实说漏嘴了，
当中是有提到的，
上海迪士尼的最大运营容量，
是八万人，
现在上海还新增了，
这个疯狂动物城，
那么理论上，
这个最大容量可能会更高，
而这个八万人的这么一个容量，
首先,
大家要理解清楚，
指的不是在项目上面的，
而是在远区里面的，
有些人可能是在路上走，
有些人可能是在餐厅里面，
有可能是在公园里面，
有可能是坐在这个长椅上面，
所有的空间加在一起，
他的容量是八万人，
那么,
其次,
不是说，
同一时间这个圆区里面，
就有八万人，
这个八万人的容量的定义是说，
因为有些人可能他是买这个下午入场圈的，
他上午不来，
下午进入这个迪士尼乐园当中，
那有些人呢，
是这个上午玩完了，
中午呢，
他觉得不想再等了，
那他就走了，对吧，
所以,
这个八万人是指的，
类似于总服务量的概念，
他不是说，
在同一时间里面，
圆区就会有八万人在走，
那我不知道，
我刷到抖音，
做分享的这个人，
是怎么找到十一万这个数字的，
我觉得也过于夸张了，
因为实际上，
迪士尼是不会去公布，
每日他的游客数量的，
他不会官方公布的，
我只在澎湃新闻的一篇报道当中，
看到说，
迪士尼乐园，
所在的这个，
上海国际旅游度假区域的核心区域，
五一的平均人次，
是十万人，
啥意思，
这里面要注意一下，
说的是，
核心区域，
是这个旅游度假区的核心区域，
它里面包括了迪士尼，
也包括迪士尼小站，
包括酒店，
包括等等的其他的空间，
这才十万，
而且这个十万说的，
不是独立人数十万，
是人次，
是十万人次，
那人数肯定是小语，
远远小语这个人次的嘛，
对不对，
所以从这个角度，
我只看到了，
十万人次这么一个说法，
所以我不知道，
这个是一万哪儿来的，
但anyway啦,。
就是当然我也没有这个证据表明，
迪士尼是抄受，
还是不是抄受的，
但是呢，
大家不要把执法部门当摆设，
中国的旅游法，
其实明确有写过，
警区接待旅游者，
不得超过，
警区主管部门，
核定的最大承载量，
所以像迪士尼这么大型的一个警区，
是不可能不被监管的，
所以呢，
这是为什么我想帮迪士尼深深冤好，
至少在容量这件事情上面，
我不太确定这个十一万跟三万的说法，
或者我完全不认可，
这个十一万跟三万的说法，
但当然我也不知道，
迪士尼是否有抄受，
我只能说相信这个监管部门，对不对？
那即便啊，
就是我们抛开刚刚说的一场串的这种容量解释，
其实很多人对于抄受或者容量这个词的认知，
说白了，
不是我们讲的这种整个圆区内的容量，
而是我希望不要排队那么久的一个舒适容量，
说白了，他就想说，
虽然这个乐园能承载八万人，
但你每天最好来三千人就好了，
对吗?
那这个听起来不是很不合理吗？
这不就意味着迪士尼需要主动放弃大量的收入吗？
作为一个商业公司，
他怎么可能做这件事情呢？
而且,
从八万人到七万人到六万人，
到底哪个合适呢？
你到了七万人，
依然会有人排队实现场，
你到了六万人，
这是一个很难被解决的问题。
而除此之外，
除了有人说要限制这个收票的数量，
限制容量，
那么另外一方面呢，
也有人说，
我们要么就扩建，
你区域更大了，
实际上可能就可以容纳更多的人了，
这个其实也是一个比较天真的想法，
首先一个新项目，
一个新援区，
动不动就是要几十亿几百亿的投资，
从立项审批建设到运营，
中间可能就好几年的时间，
更关键的是，
扩建也不一定能够真正解决问题，
因为你建得更大了，
就可能会有更多的人来，
比如说像是我，
其实我五年都没有去迪士尼了，
直到2023年，
《疯狂动物城》开了，
我才想说，
我还是去一次吧，
因为有新的援区了嘛，
对不对，
就很多人是有这种想法的，
所以这个方案，
他也不能治本嘛，
那最后一个，
是我说最有意思的一种争论，
或者说支招，
我觉得这种争论，
也已经不是在讨论排队了，
而是在讨论，
到底那些资源，
应该属于谁，
我看到一种很典型的，
特权派的观点，
他们会觉得说，
普通游客之所以，
还能买到相对便宜的门票，
本身就是因为有人花了更多的钱，
那么高消费用户，
本来就是在补贴整个乐园的运营大，
所以既然普通游客，
会因为优速通插队而破防，
那不如彻底一点，
干脆给项目上优速通游客，
一个固定的专属作为，
哪怕没人坐，
也空在那儿，
就像飞机的头顿舱那样空着，
我也不给普通游客坐，
而反过来呢，
普通派的想法也很有意思，
他们会觉得说，
哎，那既然迪士尼，
已经从特权用户那里，
赚了那么多的钱，
那就应该用这些钱，
专门打造一个特权游客自己的区域，
你特权游客住自己的酒店，
玩自己的项目，
还自己对，
不要来激战普通游客的权益嘛，
那你会发现，
这两种观点其实内核很像，
一个是在说，
既然特权要花更多的钱，
迪士尼的系统，
就应该有一部分资源天然属于特权，
另外一个则是在说，
既然特权已经花更多的钱了，
迪士尼就不应该再让这些特权。
影响公共资源，
讲到最后，
双方其实都是在争夺同一件事情嘛，
到底哪些资源是共享的，
哪些资源是专属的，
如果你认真往下想，
这两种方向其实都站不太住脚踏，
先说普通派的观点，
因为还是有点荒谬的，
它背后的逻辑，
其实就是说，
既然特权派已经买了特权，
那你迪士尼就别再让他和普通人。
共用一个系统了，
那我的反复点是什么呢，
第一,
本来整个乐园就不是属于普通派的，
很多人讨论的时候，
会不自觉地产生一种，
原本这些资源是属于普通游客的，
是特权用户用来亲战的，
但问题是，
迪士尼从来就不是一个公共福利空间，
它本身就是一个商业乐园，
所有资源本来就是你自己的，
它本来就有权决定，
到底资源怎么分配，
怎么定价，怎么卖，
其次,
如果真的按普通派的这种观点，
是非常危险的，
它的逻辑，
如果继续往下拆分，
会变得特别荒谬，
因为普通游客之间，
它的消费能力跟消费行为，
也完全不一样，
有的人竞员只卖门票，
自带水，自带面包，
完完项目就走了，
有的人会花几百块钱买桌边，
有的人会吃餐厅，
有些人会住迪士尼酒店，
是不是我还可以继续分，
再给高消费的普通游客，
专门建立一个区域，
然后只卖门票的游客，
再有自己的一个区域，
是荒谬荒谬，
所以我是不太认可普通派的这个观点，
那么特权派的观点，
有专属作为，
好像乍听一下，
也有点道理，
但是实际上是完全不符合。
商业运营逻辑的，
我们前面讲了这么多，
其实迪士尼项目运营的核心之一，
就是吞吐量，
跟排队管理，对不对，
一个热门项目一小时能接待多少人，
这件事情是非常重要的，
因为整个乐园的排队实践，
游客体验，
菜饮消费，商店消费，
全部都和这个吞吐量，
绑定的，
今天优速通人多，
就多放优速通，
今天优速通人少，
普通队伍就应该去吃掉。
这些控于的作为，
它的核心逻辑是不浪费，
这是迪士尼的核心逻辑，
如果真相特权派说的那种，
固定20%-30%的作为给优速通，
哪怕没人做，也必须空着，
既收不到优速通的钱，
又让普通游客的体验差，
未来不会再来，
这不就是很可惜的一件事情吗？
所以迪士尼的逻辑，
就应该是，
如果今天优速通多了，
虽然挤压了普通游客的体验，
但至少我赚到了优速通的钱了，
同理如果今天优速通少了，
普通游客可以更快地玩上，
体验好了，
下次可能还会再来，
这部分未来的钱我也能确保，
这就是商业平衡吗？
所以关于专属之争，
权力之争，
我也不同于特权派的观点，
我也不同于普通派的观点，
那么说到这里，
小伙伴就会说，
你一味的反驳，
你觉得要怎么办？
我其实也没有答案，
如果有的话，
迪士尼早就应该挖我过去了，
又能让所有人满意，
又能让迪士尼最大花赚钱，
想什么美事呢？
如果是站在游客的视角，
我当然我的建议就是公开化，
透明化信息，
不管是门票，
每天预计限额多少，
优速通预计限额多少，
这样子至少能保证大家。
能够凭自己的判断，
去与不去，
而不产生抱怨，
但如果我现在在迪士尼上班，
提议这么干，
我一定会被开除的，
没什么好说的，
对不对？
所以我实在是没有其他招了，
但不管如何，
我觉得唯一比较确定的是什么呢？
这种付费的速通票，
绝对是不会被取消的，
就像我们前面提到的，
纵观迪士尼的人流排队管理系统的这种历史，
速通票是非常非常成功的，
至少免费式的，
只是这个系统已经像一个时间怪兽一样，
越变越大了，
一开始是个小怪兽，
随着游客的喜欢，
迪士尼就更激进地发放速通票了，
速通票发的越多，
游客越熟悉，
就越想要，
需求也就上去了，
需求上去了，
又会发放的更多，
于是这个怪兽
就会吃掉更多的时间，
越变越大，
以免费的机制，
也如了付费的机制，
迪士尼乐园的收入急速的上涨，
这个怪兽的成长，
是不可能停下来的，
你不可能杀死这个怪兽，
所以最后，迪士尼可能，
只是需要一套能更好的。
駕馭这个怪兽的方法而已。
好，那么以上就是今天全部内容了，
如果对于本期内容。
感兴趣的听友们，
欢迎留言，
大家来一起讨论讨论，
我觉得还是一个
非常有意思的话题的，
那么如果想要加入我们的听友群，
也可以在收诺当中，
找到和加入。
好，本期到此结束，
下期再见，
拜拜!